sorry so block the check yeah and he's
lined it up so beautifully I mean
there's no tactics whatsoever in Eric's
favor and he moves his Rook tactics
against the black king
you see what's happening yeah we're
gonna see actually Magnus go on the
attack uh the black king when it moves
to this okay is Eric gonna resign
because if you block this check it's
pretty much the same as resigning right
um you can drop back with the black Rook
or the black Bishop but if the King goes
to the edge of the board the White
Knight is going to jump into the center
and start going for the black king
okay we'll see this on the board
it's the white knight will jump to the
middle and attack the rook and also
threaten the F7 Pawn and the black king
is in a mating net yeah I think we're
going to see just body language wise
Eric is about to resign any moment
and there we go the black Christmas
attack the black porn was attacked
nothing to be done yeah it's a win for
Magnus Carlsen striking back after